[تصفيق]
لمحاكمه ترامب التي تشعر امريكا والعالم
اليوم جانب اخر فالرئيس السابق والممثله
الاباحيه
يكسبان من قضيتهما ملايين الدولارات حمله
ترامب وقبل الاعلان عن لائحه الاتهامات
بحقه دعت مناصريه لدفع الاموال عبر شراء
قميص كتب عليه انا اقف مع ترامب
تقول الحمله انها جمعت اربعه ملايين دولار
خلال 24 ساعه فقط من توجيه التهم للترامب
من بيع القميص بسعر 47 دولارا كذلك جلبت
القضيه مكاسب غير متوقعه للممثله الاباحيه
دانيلز حيث كانت عائدات السوشيال ميديا
تتدفق بلا توقف عدا عائدات عرض البضائع
عبر موقعها الرسمي بما في ذلك قمصان بقيمه
عشرين دولار وملصقات موقعه منها ودمن تشبه
ترامب ب 30 دولار عبر بث مباشر ردد دانيلز
على الانتقادات حول محاولاتها الكسب من
هذه القضيه قائله ان كل شخص لديه شركه
يبيع السلع عبرها والرئيس ترامب يستخدم
القضيه ايضا لكسب الاموال
وبينما تترقب الولايات المتحده ما ستؤول
اليه قضيه شراء الصمت ومعها العالم الرئيس
السابق عالم يبدو يستثمر في كل شيء حتى
وان كانت القضيه تهدده شخصيه
[تصفيق]